[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome to
Stanford Graduate School of Business,
my name is Sawyer Clark and
I am a first year MBA here at the GSB.
Some of my classmates and I are going to
show you around our campus today.
[MUSIC]
As we walk forward we're walking
away from the GSB residences,
which are just across
the street in that direction.
And we're heading into what's
called the Town Square,
this is very much the center of and
the lifeblood of our community.
You'll see people all around me, meeting
both students, faculty, classmates of
mine, as well as guests, or other people
that are affiliated with the school.
To my left you’ll also see Cooper Cafe,
which is a coffee shop where many of my
friends and myself meet to get
coffee between or before classes.
Above Cooper Cafe are many of the faculty
offices, as well as the adverb wall
of change, which describes the many
ways we can change in life.
To my right is Arbuckle Cafe,
which is the main dining hall for
all the students at the GSB.
[MUSIC]
>> My name is Carla Larin, I'm an MBA 1.
Students use the Bass Library mostly for
studying and also for group projects.
I like to go to the Bass Library to get
my case readings done before classes.
And I also go weekly for
leadership coaching from my
Arbuckle leadership fellow.
>> My name is Piyush Pratik, I'm an MBA 2.
Classes at the GSB are taught
by both practitioners and
tenured faculty to provide both
research and industry perspective.
What's great about the GSB is that we
don't have any one method of teaching,
we have several.
There are, of course,
the case methods and the lectures.
But we also have a ton of experiencial
learning opportunities where we apply
concepts learned in class
into actual projects.
We don't just learn in
a traditional classroom,
there are a lot of hands
on learning opportunities.
Many of these courses take place at
the CoLab, where in fact I'm headed next.
>> Hi, my name is Tamar Nisbett and
I'm an MBA 1 here at Stanford GSB.
The CoLab is a community space
where Stanford GSB students and
their cofounders can come together
to work on their startups.
It's also an innovation hub where any
Standford student can get exposure
to design thinking.
The CoLab is home to classic
Stanford startup classes,
like Startup Garage and Venture Studio.
And huge companies,
like DoorDash, have come from it.
One of my favorite companies that's being
worked on right now is called Praxis Lab.
It's a diversity and
inclusion startup that uses AR and
VR to help engender empathy in others.
One of the best parts about the CoLab is
that it's open 24, 7 so when the coffee
shop is closed everyone can come and
work on their start up together here.
>> [INAUDIBLE] a second year
MBA student from India.
We are here at the Arbuckle Dining
at the center of the GSB.
With its indoor and outdoor seating this
part serves as a natural meeting point for
me and my friends as we catch up over
lunch or dinner, discussing our future,
working on our class projects,
and thinking about our failures.
One of my favourite memories here
is catching up with my classmates,
learning about their cultures, and
cuisines while we share lunch or dinner.
Arbuckle has a variety of options to
choose from, ranging from grilled items,
pizzas, salads, daily changing global
cuisine, seasonal soups, and fresh fish.
I love that Arbuckle
also serves Indian food,
something that I thought I
would miss when I move here.
Right outside Arbuckle is the Monument
to Change art installation,
it reminds me that the future
is always changing.
And I've got to be
evolving to change lives,
change organizations,
and change the world.
>> Hi, I'm Renata Giarola, and
I'm an MBA 1 here at the GSB,
I'm originally from Brazil, and
I moved here from Australia.
Stanford students are known for whenever
we have the chance we go outside and
study for meetings, for
preparing presentations.
We always reading and doing, maximizing
our time outside, which is really great.
I didn't realize that
the GSB campus would be so
integrated with where
most of the people live.
So it's awesome that we can go to class,
go to meetings, go to speaker events,
host small group dinners,
everything within the same small radius.
So there is no typical
day here at the GSB.
What I love the most about living here at
Jack McDonough Hall is that not only it's
super close to the GSB campus,
but it creates this amazing,
beautiful sense of community.
After a typical day here at the GSB I like
getting to my room and taking the time to
really shut down and I usually do that
by journaling and writing about my day.
[MUSIC]
>> My name is Abioduri Buari, the great
thing about being a GSB student is
being able to take classes at any
school at Stanford University.
It gives you the opportunity to
explore the Stanford campus.
[MUSIC]
>> At Stanford Gradate School of
Business you are more than a student,
you’re part of the vibrant GSB community.
From your classroom experience
to your active social life,
from forging great relationships with
classmates and faculty to becoming part of
the larger Stanford network you’ll
find endless possibilities.
We hope to see you here.
[MUSIC]